a teacher from the
Ford County School District Says she was
brutally attacked by a student how does she
greet Cristian Castro with her own
It is now newscast in Spanish the
teacher who prefers to keep her
identity and that of the school
downbeat says it was  attacked when she
tried to separate two students who
were fighting She says she received
several blows while trying to
separate the two young people according to whether there were more
than 5,300 cases of violence
reported so far this school year
Pop singer Justin Bieber canceled
his concert  the night he
tests positive for coronavirus his team
says that he only had mild symptoms
this presentation was scheduled for
June 28 he can turn in his ticket
to get the money invested or he can
use it in the function that will be held
in June he
reaches his new  goal over the
weekend the wedding capital of the world
delivered the
5,000,000th marriage license congratulations  s to Luis
Pantoja and Mayra Ramírez from San José
they received Fabulous prizes such as
a night for two in the country a
spa package including a ring and of course much
more Congratulations to the newlyweds and the
Strong winds continue throughout
the Bayetamos temperatures in the 50s
until Mid week with a
chance of rain for
Tuesday night and Wednesday morning
cooler for a few days but
temperatures will rise for the latter
[Music]